all right joining us now is ohio senate
candidate jd vance jd um
this axios piece really struck me
because
the media are seeing
this kind of globalist
dream world beginning to fade away for
them
because more people are on to this you
know total charade
how do you see this playing out with
this new crop of republicans coming into
the republican party
well i think we have an incredible
opportunity laura to actually do
something for the increasingly working
and middle class base of the party i
think president trump delivered in a big
way but as you know he was often not
aligned with his own party and i think
that if we really win the way that we
should in 22 and we start to deliver
results we're going to have a republican
party at every level that's actually
aligned with its own voters and then
we're going to be unstoppable because we
can accomplish on trade on immigration
on fighting china bringing american
manufacturing jobs back on securing the
southern border we can actually do the
things that republicans have promised do
to do for a long time but have failed to
do
this new
insight from the hill tonight that
republicans are actively courting
hispanic voters in key competitive house
districts hoping to peel away voters
from democrats the voters are likely to
play a key role in at least a dozen
districts in the november midterms jd i
know you've been asking for this i have
for a long time but it is long since
time that the republicans did the type
of minority outreach with the right
ideas that they're finally doing now
yeah that's exactly right and for so
long everybody told us that the way to
reach the hispanic vote was to go soft
on borders and it turns out laura the
exact opposite thing is true that the
more we lean into protecting the
southern border the more that we lean
into giving our police officers the
ability to protect our communities the
more hispanics come to our side yeah i i
think there's this way where the
establishment republicans and also the
the left shared this assumption that
identity politics was the way to reach
out to latinos it turns out the way to
reach out to latinos is to be normal not
be a crazy person and actually talk to
them in a way that serves their
interests and to appeal to those
interests that's that's simple
old-fashioned politics and the
republican party has a huge opportunity
to do that
and the so-called democrat populist the
ones who claim to be for the working
people we see this with the squad and so
forth they never help the working people
stacy abrams who wants to uh of course
uh take out brian camp in georgia
it turns out that she's getting
blockbuster fundraising numbers from out
of state money and her campaign and
leadership committee have reported
receiving about seven million dollars
from georgia donors that's only 14
percent of the nearly 50 million
they've combined to raise this cycle
turns out that the plutocrats
love stacey abrams jd that's interesting
what do they think they're going to get
from her
yeah they do and they love tim ryan my
democrat opponent in in ohio here look
the thing with the democrats do if you
look at their record they're completely
aligned with big tech they're completely
aligned with big finance they're
completely aligned with the people that
are destroying america's energy sector
which hurts the working middle class
more than it hurts anybody else and
you're right that these people have a
ton of money from these out-of-state
donors my opponent tim ryan is is got
something like 90 of his money has come
from outside the state of ohio people
can go by the way to jdvance.com if they
want to help us fight back laura because
this money is the one thing that could
blunt a red wave and it's not just a red
wave but it's the right kind of
republicans coming into dc that could
actually fix the problems and fight back
once and for all i understand that tim
ryan is also just abusing
the proxy voting that nancy pelosi is
still
in a mind-boggling way allowing on
capitol hill so no one's essential they
never have to show up and actually work
on capitol hill but mr populist shirt
sleeves guy who's going to help the
regular person can't actually show up in
washington to do his job i understand
yeah and i don't know what's worse him
showing up to do his job or not showing
up to do his job laura because he's
voted with joe biden 100 of the time
it is hilarious that a guy who claims to
speak for working people is claiming two
years after the pandemic that covet
prevents him from showing up and doing
his job it's predic it's ridiculous it's
a farce but again that's the democratic
populist they are all about identity
politics
defunding the police they're fakes
they're not pursuing populist issues
they just want to put on you know that
populist guard raise some money and
hopefully get power so that they can
continue to serve the american oligarchy
instead of the american people yeah a
vote for tim ryan is a vote to keep
nancy pelosi as uh speaker and chuck
schumer frankly a senate majority leader
the whole the whole gang will be back in
town jd great to see you thank you hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else